It had been a long dig, expeditions like
this were normally tiring. But with the
intense heat of the Egyptian sun bearing
down on them, every minute felt like hours,
and every hour a lifetime. Seth and Kayla were
determined not to quit, they had traveled halfway
around the world to get to this site, and they
weren’t about to let the elements stop them from
uncovering the secrets they were searching for.
The rumors had dated back centuries, stories of
a hidden tomb lost somewhere out in the desert.
And as a likely pair of a budding adventurer
and an accomplished archaeologist, neither one of
them could resist the chance to try and hunt down
the tomb. If they could uncover it, they’d have
one of the greatest archaeological finds of the
century on their hands, both Kayla and Seth
would be forever remembered as the ones who
discovered a supposedly unfindable ancient tomb.
Having found their way to some ruins, the remains
of a temple that had been all but razed to
the ground, ravaged by the forces of time,
Kayla and Seth had started searching for the
tomb’s entrance. The reason it had stayed
undiscovered for so long was the amount of sand
that had covered it over the centuries, storms
from the desert constantly rearranging the grains
and piling on more. But right now, the skies were
clear, and all they could do was keep digging.
Until, at long last, their shovels struck stone.
Clearing a path to the entrance, Kayla flipped on
a torch as she led her archaeologist friend down
a flight of stairs carved into the stone. Seth
followed as they traverse further and further
down, the air getting stale the deeper they
went. The whole while, there was a gnawing
concern at the back of both their minds, that the
rocky ceiling above could give way at any moment,
trapping them both underground. But before either
one of them could voice their worry out loud,
they arrived at a large stone door, left wide
open about twenty meters beneath the surface.
“Is this really it?” Kayla asked in disbelief.
“It might be,” Seth replied, the excitement in
his voice like that of a kid on Christmas morning.
Standing before them, beyond the threshold of the
open entrance, was a chamber of stone. Its
ceiling was secure, about seven meters high,
and the walls had been covered in hieroglyphics.
Immediately, Seth shot over to the nearest wall,
pulling a battered journal out of his bag to
start trying to translate what had been written.
While he was doing that, Kayla’s attention
fell over the rest of the room. For a tomb,
there was a surprising lack of a sarcophagus,
nor any other similar resting place for a body,
with no signs that anyone else had
already been here to remove one either.
All there really was within was a few
bowls, randomly placed around the chamber.
Kayla’s torchlight fell over one of the bowls,
and she knelt down to take a closer look at its
contents. It was filled with bread, they were all
holding different foods, dates, figs, dried fish,
and lentils. Of course, it wasn’t uncommon for
offerings to be left with the deceased during
an Ancient Egyptian burial. But strangely, none
of these perishable foods seemed to have decayed
in the centuries this tomb had been lost for;
in fact, it all looked fresh, like it was still
good enough to eat. Although the temptation to
actually eat any of it quickly disappeared when
Kayla reminded herself that – while it might
not look it – the food down here had to have
been hundreds, maybe thousands of years old,
despite how perfectly preserved it appeared.
“I think I’ve got something!” Seth called
enthusiastically. “There’s definitely
a story in these hieroglyphics.”
“You sure we’re in the right place?”
Kayla asked as she crossed the room to
where her colleague was. “For a tomb,
it doesn’t seem like anyone was ever buried here.”
“I’ve got a theory,” he replied. “This place
might be more of a… metaphorical tomb.”
“Right, that makes complete sense.” Her
sarcasm was unmistakable.
“Look, here,” he said,
pointing to one of the drawings on the wall
as he spoke. It depicted a figure, laying
dead in a square space. “I think that’s meant
to be this room, someone dies here, and then…”
Seth’s finger moved to another of the hieroglyphs,
one that Kayla recognized. It showed a being with
the body of a man and the head of a jackal,
taking the dead figure down into the afterlife.
This was Anubis, one of the Ancient Egyptian
gods associated with the afterlife. According
to legends and other text gathered from the
pyramids in Giza, Anubis oversaw the process
the Egyptians would perform to embalm their dead,
preserving them for their trip to the next world.
“Anubis takes whoever they are to the judgment
hall of the afterlife to be brought before-”
Seth explained, only to be cut off.
“Osiris, god of fertility, the afterlife,
and the dead,” Kayla interrupted; she had already
spotted the next being depicted in the glyphs,
a tall figure with a distinctive headpiece,
holding a symbolic crook and flail. “Oversaw
resurrection, life, probably many other things.”
“Yeah, he was a god with a few different hats,”
Seth attempted to joke. “Well, just the same one
hat he’s always shown wearing. Also, technically
not a hat, the atef was a type of crown and-”
“So, hold on,” Kayla interjected again. “Didn’t
Osiris only bring the pharaohs in for judgment?
Who was this person that died? I mean the
Egyptians never went to this amount of trouble for
their Average Joes, and the gods wouldn’t pay them
any mind unless they were important somehow.”
“I’m not sure,” Seth answered earnestly,
“At any rate, this could all be a myth.
That’s why I think this tomb is metaphorical,
it wasn’t built to house a dead person…”
“But to keep people believing,”
she finished his sentence for him.
He then pointed out the next part of the glyphs,
the dead figure arriving in the afterlife, carried
by Anubis for judgment, and then handing an object
to Osiris. Seth explained there was a certain
myth surrounding Osiris and his resurrection,
a story that told of all his dead body
parts being found, except one. Without it,
the god could not be fully resurrected.
“My theory is that is Osiris’ ‘missing
appendage’ as it were,” Seth’s face went
red as he tried to keep his composure.
“After our mysterious friend handed it over…”
The hieroglyphs showed the nameless dead figure
being taken from Anubis’ hand by Osiris, who then
placed them back in the room they had started in;
the same chamber Seth and Kayla were standing in.
It seemed they’d been resurrected after death,
giving Osiris something that the god wanted
had earned this figure a free pass back to
the land of the living. The glyphs also showed
bowls of food around the tomb, like the ones
Kayla had found dotted around the room.
There was a type of aura drawn around
the unknown figure now, almost like a personal
shield. According to the drawings and symbols
on the walls, and Seth’s hasty translation of
their meaning, this was some form of protection
granted by Osiris himself. The aura was meant
to prevent the figure from harm, meaning they
couldn’t die again. However, the next portion
of the story showed Anubis damaging this shield,
possibly out of jealousy and spite, or perhaps
defying Osiris tampering with the natural
order of things by protecting the figure from
death. As well as causing damage to the aura of
immortality that Osiris had bestowed on them,
Anubis drained the figure of all their blood.
“Which then caused them to go and do the same
to others,” Seth continued interpreting aloud.
“It would find people, drink
their blood to sustain it like-”
“Don’t say it,” Kayla sighed.
“I mean, it is a lot like a vam-”
“Egypt gave us mummies, they can’t
have another native monster from
horror B-movies,” she interrupted.
“Well, maybe the legend found its
way here somehow, or at least a more Ancient
Egyptian version of it,” her counterpart tried
to reason. “It looks like here, the figure
was far healthier after consuming blood,
see how the aura around them is repaired now.”
“But, Seth, look at what they’re
standing on…” Kayla whispered.
One of the final images in the glyphs
did display exactly what Seth had described. But
beneath the feet of the figure, who now seemed
replenished, was a mass of bodies, a pile of human
corpses with one person standing at the very top.
“Who’d want to live forever anyway?”
Kayla muttered almost inaudibly. “Hey,
come and have a look at these.”
Leaning over, she picked up one of
the food bowls from the floor, brimming with
offerings of dates. She handed it to Seth,
who marveled at how well preserved the food was.
“That’s incredible,” he remarked. “This bowl
looks like it’s at least several thousand years
old, I’d guess maybe 2500 BCE. But the dates…”
he picked one out of the bowl, sniffed it,
put it back, then did the same with another,
making sure it wasn’t a fluke. “The conditions
couldn’t possibly have kept them this fresh.”
“So, how is it that there are bowls of food all
over this room that still look edible?” she asked.
“I honestly have no-” he began to say.
The sound of heavy, grinding stone
interrupted Seth’s sentence. Both he and Kayla
looked in horror as they witness the entrance
of the tomb being sealed, the heavy stone door
dropping, moments away from sealing them in.
“Seth, we need to run!” Kayla urged,
grabbing her bag. “If we move now,
we can get out before we get shut in here.”
“But…” Seth protested, looking around the tomb,
the glyph walls that had only just been
discovered; nobody would know that he and
Kayla had found them if they ran now. He looked
around the room, pondering for a moment, his eyes
darting from a bowl of bread, to the bowl of dates
in his hands. “We should at least take photos!”
“No time! Our lives aren’t
worth proving what we found,
better to make it out than be buried alive,”
Kayla shouted, darting towards the entrance,
ducking under the slowly lowering stone door.
“Seth, come on!” she called from the other side.
Despite her calls for him to move, her fellow
explorer didn’t follow. He just stood there,
watching the door get lower and the only
way back to the surface get narrower. By
the time it had completely closed, Kayla’s
voice sounded so much further away that
Seth could barely make out what she was saying.
“I’ll get help, find some way to get you out!”
Kayla screamed at the wall now separating
her from the tomb. “If you can hear me,
Seth, ration the water in your bag,
take small sips every few hours.”
Seth already knew the human body could survive
around three weeks on just water and no food,
and he trusted Kayla would have figured out how
to get him out by then. He gave another glance to
the food bowls scattered throughout the tomb. The
idea of eating any of it, knowing how old it all
potentially was, did turn his stomach a little.
But if it came down to having to eat just a bite
in order to survive a little longer, Seth was
sure it looked fresh enough to still be edible.
It couldn’t hurt to take a bite, right?
Over the next few days, Seth’s focus was
spent entirely on photographing and
transcribing more of the hieroglyphs,
occasionally stopping to take swigs of water
from his canteen. If anything, it was more to
combat how warm and stuffy it was being locked
in a stone chamber twenty meters underground.
Meanwhile, unseen to Seth, outside Kayla
was working tirelessly to try and figure
out a way to get the door open. She had been
searching for days for any sign of some kind of
switch or lever that would unseal the chamber
entrance. There had to be some mechanism that
had caused the stone door to shut itself in
the first place, but there was nothing around
that looked like it fit that description.
As much as she had urged Seth to abandon his
archaeological ‘finders-keepers’ pride, Kayla was
hesitant to make the long journey back across the
desert to Cairo to get help. Anyone she brought
to the dig site might claim the discovery as
their own, and more to the point, the more time
she spent traveling across the desert for help,
the more time Seth would spend trapped,
succumbing to gradual dehydration and starvation.
Little was Kayla aware; it was already too late.
Seth hadn’t been observing her warning about
managing the amount he was drinking, and pretty
soon his canteen was empty. He cursed himself,
annoyed for being so involved in his discovery
that he’d now potentially put his own life at
risk. But then, he remembered the food bowls.
Kneeling down, he picked up the nearest one, the
same bowl with all the dates in it. Shaking his
head at the thought, he put them back down again.
The longer he waited, the more Seth began to
worry that maybe Kayla had abandoned him. And if
she had, then he was faced with the inevitability
that he would die down here, lost and forgotten
in an ancient tomb underground. He couldn’t help
but find something ironic about the whole thing,
he was going to die in a tomb whose walls told a
tale of a dead person being brought back to life.
Maybe in another few hundred years, more
archaeologists would find this buried room
and think he was the one the tomb had been
constructed for. Even trying to put an ironic
spin on things wasn’t enough to give Seth much
peace when staring down the possibility he might
not see the sun and walk above ground again. And
getting closer to death is what made him want to
avoid it, tempting him toward the bowls of food.
Every time he tried to tell himself not to touch
any of it, the pain in his stomach swelled even
greater, reminding him of his own hunger. With
no clear view of the sky, Seth had little clue
just how many days he’d been trapped in the tomb,
although he was sure it was approaching the day
four threshold. He couldn’t survive much longer
beyond that point without eating. As the
days dragged on, he abandoned his research
and note-taking, it was impossible to focus on
translating hieroglyphs when he was in so much
pain, aching from the heat and having no food
or water, exhaustion causing him to pass out,
his body trying to conserve its
already limited reserves of energy.
Eventually, Seth started trying to rationalize
eating at least a date or two. The food hadn’t
decomposed or rotted at all, even introducing
air from outside when the tomb was first opened
hadn’t changed the state of any of it at
all; not the dates, nor the bread or the
fish. It still looked fresh and edible, and
after God knows how long without eating,
it was beginning to look all the more appealing
to the starving archaeologist. Who cares if it had
been there for a thousand years or longer? If Seth
didn’t eat, he knew he wouldn’t last much longer.
The moment he chewed on the first date, feeling it
pass down his esophagus, passing from his mouth to
his stomach, Seth immediately regretted giving in
to his need to eat. His mouth instantly went dry,
far worse than it had been after this long
without water. It was like the tiny piece of
fruit had pulled all the saliva from his mouth.
Seth tried to scream in pain, only to release a
hoarse, dry-throated gasp as he felt his tongue
shriveling up along with his mouth and throat,
until it felt like the skin of a drum.
But it didn’t stop there, it only got
worse. Seth stared in horror at his own arms, the
blue veins that ran underneath his skin rapidly
draining away. His forearms and biceps shrunk,
muscle and sinews shriveling like his body had
been left in a water evaporator. All the while,
the pain of having his entire physical form being
reshaped was pure agony, the dehydration of
his mouth meant Seth still couldn’t scream,
only drop to the ground as he felt
the same thing happening to his legs.
Every drop of moisture in his body, every fluid
from water to blood, saliva, and even urine was
drying out, leaving Seth as little more than
a dusty, desiccated husk. Before his own eyes,
he could only watch as his skin lost its pigment,
drying into a thin, leathery texture, drained of
its original color as his blood stopped flowing.
Outside, Kayla had been coming back to the tomb’s
sealed stone door every day, and would stay
until the late hours of the evening. She’d
tried digging down from the surface to reach
the chamber where Seth had been trapped,
but it was too far underground. There was no sign
of any way to move or reopen the stone door… that
is, until she heard the heavy grinding of it
opening on its own. Kayla raced down the steps
towards the tomb. It had been five whole days
since she and Seth got separated, and he’d need
food and medical attention. Sprinting into the
dark tunnel, she arrived just in time to see the
entrance reopening, expecting to see Seth standing
on the other side as the stone door lifted.
What she saw instead was a nightmare. It looked
like a corpse, an ancient and decomposed dead
body. Kayla had seen plenty entombed in sarcophagi
on her many travels exploring ancient ruins
around the world. But she had never seen one
standing up. It was still breathing, a wheezing,
raspy sound escaping its mouth. Its skin looked
almost brittle as if it was stretched too thin,
almost see-through enough to show off the bones
underneath. The upright corpse’s face was all
wrong too, sunken cheeks and eye sockets deeper
than they should have been. It looked so different
that it wasn’t until Kayla shone her flashlight on
its drained face that she recognized who it was.
Seth.
He lunged at her immediately, racing towards her,
snarling with his dry, desiccated mouth. Kayla
turned and ran as he came after her, bony fingers
swiping at her clothes. Her flashlight gripped in
her hand was all but useless as she sprinted back
the way she’d come, swinging back and forth in her
arm, barely illuminating much of the cavern that
led to the tomb. The whole while she was running
from it, she could hear the wheezing breaths
of Seth behind her, terrified of whatever
he had become, and why he was chasing her.
Then she saw it; the stairs, her one shot at
getting out and getting away. If she could make it
to the surface, she could put some more distance
between herself and the drained, dehydrated
corpse. All she had to do was make it up…
The last step, she had just made it when
she felt the shriveled hand grip her ankle,
tripping her over. Falling face-first in the sand,
Kayla scrabbled at the loose grains, trying
to pull herself away as her body was dragged
back down onto the stone stairs. She felt a
searing pain and screamed into the empty desert,
as the corpse’s fingers dug into her
neck, its leathery, dry skin against hers.
Eventually, the screaming stopped, replaced
with a dry, hoarse gasping, and then silence,
as Seth drained her body of her blood, along with
the rest. Pulling Kayla’s body by her ankle, Seth
dragged what was left of her back down towards
the tomb, SCP-3359, to feed on what was left.
Now go and check out “SCP-1176 WHY EVERYONE WANTS
TO EAT THIS CORPSE” for even more mysterious
mummified madness. Or, if ancient temples are
more your thing, then why not take a visit to
“SCP-001 GOD’S BLIND SPOT” and uncover some
sinister secrets with some anomalous archaeology.